left it short George the rebound a
little bit of time here for the Thunder
I'm attending this trip I'm gonna check
the replay with Paul George at the
buzzer the third quarter and regulation
[Applause]
he scores as time runs out
the Pistons Bob Reggie P and Dwayne
Casey
guess what has to be one of these
players feel how much they care about
Dwane Casey and they get him a win
Reggie Bullock Dwayne bacon on him
Jimmy Butler can he win it here it is
Butler for the win buries the three with
three tenths of a second ago
Hornets without any timeouts the pair
from Walker goes unanswered and the
Sixers win
[Applause]
it's on the road when things are looking
tough you bring it on home with a big
time shot see his teammates love it in
right now look at that that's pretty
good defense as well I mean that's the
kind of shot you go no no no yes after
it falls in offered outside they were
trying to get into the hands of hooker
but instead Jake cross all the way that
raising up for the shot and cashing in
the mid range the veteran Jake crossover
with knocks it down goes right by
Brogdon and nails it
[Music]
porns over time
Lan's gonna have to fire
[Applause]
winning shot as a Hornet how about this
give it six assists in the first half to
the second but that was the biggest one
right there
tie game with 2.5 left 48
[Applause]
this is gonna count Evan with a nice
and you can see its weight out of his
hands before the light comes on
game-winning shots for Evan Fournier he
has been mr. clutch for the magic the
last several years and he comes through
again on a Sunday afternoon inside the
Amway Center thrilling finish to this
one let's check in with Dante and Evan
for he yes but he gets the basketball
bobbles it a little bit doesn't lose his
poise puts it back down on the floor
reaches up that is a one leg or take it
dagger
buddy hield for uno dos tres well I'll
pay this you can say the Sacramento
Kings with this kick but you know what
they won the game they stole the game
[Applause]
so to trap the pushin
look for the pick-and-roll is someone to
the corner not a second
[Applause]
be a pick-and-roll Hayward hopped up on
the corners he tries to come in but this
is why you keep it alive Chandler played
less than five minutes this whole game
he tips it out Rondo with the kiss
knocking it down making sure that he
gets this win so important for guys to
come home to that all arenas get the
game Chandler again less than five
minutes played in this game Rondo bang
[Music]
water tremendous game between two
longtime rival
[Applause]
the colors proudly here Pepsi Center and
how about the assists by Monta Morris
right on the money you guys used to plan
together working together
[Applause]
one to go there off the steel in
transition
long distance bomb from George keeping
the hopes of the Thunder alive
10 seconds one weighed against Iguodala
five seconds left
waiters back to 12 shoots no I couldn't
get it off that fires it
again
126 to 125
and just happened
in his final game against the Golden
State Warriors Dwayne Wade beats two
worries rate five seconds
summers bringing in five seconds ago tie
game seatbelts are fastened Luke
Williams for the win
[Music]
goodness that just happened
Lu little become everybody in the gym
knew Lou Wales was going to shoot this
shot Beasley got it off in time and got
nothing but nylon
and the play before he gives it up he
says I'm not passing this and me going
to his left route it doesn't get me
better runner looks blades it into tray
two seconds watch rays flutter
[Applause]
ever
shame
what a play by Trey young the Florida
that he has perfected and get all the
love on the sideline no man he has put
together a heck of a game Berger gets it
in Kevin looking lob to the basket poked
away
[Applause]
Anna quits it in overtime the basket is
good video reviews
[Applause]
[Music]
barely any time a crisp all through it
up from well beyond mid-corner that went
in the buzzer
off the glass out it's a chance to send
the Thunder home Willard long-range
three
[Applause]
dagger oh my goodness look at that shot
to put them out he went 450
that was forty seven forty eight nine
and fifty points on that was not amazing
five years ago
three against your rocket yes
when the first round series
[Applause]
for 50 points
goodnight Oklahoma City sees it over
here if you're filling it's off the
Leonard defended by Simmons is this
[Applause]
fifteen fourth-quarter points by Kawhi
Leonard and game-winner 41 points
[Applause]
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content